oh Jesus Jesus and also Jesus we're
getting close his birthday hi block miss
oh man did I not do vlogmas this weekend
should be expected whoa there's some
blood was from last like Thursday Friday
but I didn't post my dog throwing up no
she's just chewing a toy I've got a
helicopter mom I said good morning vomit
good morning Blackman I stayed up very
late last night blog man I'm an adult
man man isn't this the picture of
maturity
it's vlogmas day five Thursday that
Thursday it's Thursday wrong man oh we
gotta make coffee oh my god could you
hate being exploited more like you know
like you're just choosing not to use
your words it's not vlogmas until we
make copy what content
I like flavor coffee because basically
I'm a yummy adult yummy adult means that
it's adults that don't grow out of like
the childhood taste bud face I like
people that like never want to try like
cigars or a beer or like briny flavor
it's a whole thing Adam Carolla created
this theory I'm in my yummy coffee taste
you know like when you have eyeliner
left on from the night before this is
real blog minutes none of those beauty
gurus are showing you this content it's
on that biscotti flavored I guess like
this really complicated and difficult
what what mug do I want oh my god oh
he's also doing blog let's go check it
out on your channel promote we're
friends but like we're real friends no
way oh [ __ ] is that amazing or was that
amazing it's just a cold case you nice
that angle today we are entering vlogmas
from yesterday hello life is cyclical
and kind of depressing I haven't bought
my family any Christmas present family
stop watching if you're watching this
right now I know you're watching this
because I haven't called home and this
is the only way that you know that I'm
still alive appreciate your loyal
viewership bad hi
suited this channel my name is grace
Helbig I don't normally do videos like
this but because it's blog mess and Dame
vlog man if you don't know me on a
personal level I'm about to give you my
entire life story in one panning shot
[Music]
and that's me grace on how big the first
subscribe blog rest headlock masses vlog
man I fell asleep nap that's what
they're called I took a nap now I'm
going to edit my focus for today oh my
god I'd like to speak the most thrilling
times of all times cool I'm gonna go eat
some peanut butter
looking very below average so we are
uploading vlogmas day for right now
check it out if you're watching this
behind but how how do you cook thank you
for cutting me off where I get some
fresh air so we're gonna take loose for
a walk do you wanna go for a walk would
you like to go for a walk yeah I know
it's gonna happen I my god oh my god oh
my god
[ __ ] and talking it's vlog minute I'm
when going back to see you I'm getting
drinks with a friend tonight which is
exciting business walking talking
botanist I've got math I did the hygiene
thing nailing it nailing it's just
relatable I'm announced Sunday here's
some recap of what happened this weekend
hi snapchat I was having a really
awesome night in I was making myself
dinner I was just relaxing and then all
of my pipes broke again and there's just
gross brown liquid everywhere in every
toilet every shower every everything I'm
not gonna snap it cuz it's just
straight-up disgusting goose and I are
crashing at Mary's house while she's in
Palm Springs for the weekend
Thank You mamrie Hart for allowing us an
abode with toilets that work oh and I
packed some Jawas and treats and toys
for goose and then they also made sure
that I packed choice for me to make
different come on I sent that
mamrie did I think about her yes did I
go in your hot tub yes then I put on
your American flag onesie
yes am i sorry about I knew that
yesterday Saturday my body just shut
down like refused to leave bed and I
slept for like 15 hours like on and off
I have crazy dreams that felt like real
life it's amazing when you push your
body really fought your body pushes back
man so it turns out I'm not in the West
world because I am human and I am unless
that was part of my story narrative was
I just recharging that's Sunday and I'm
doing the most generic Sunday of all
Sunday but anxious together in my home
doing laundry doing domestic life
getting back on track here's a cool
thing I ordered a bench from West Elm
like months ago and it finally got here
hey buddy don't put that together yeah
maybe that's interesting content
[Music]
you get this you'll just you get it
Oh lights lights right like ha that
there's nothing like this I didn't show
you the final bench outcome here it is I
don't know what's on it oh no that's
just what does something get there's
some stain on it already
perfect it's super cute I like it very
much I got to figure out how it fits in
here
classic I'm gonna go have dinner with
Jocelyn huge you know Jocelyn DIY damn
it urban vlogging just walk into the
loudest area of my house or like just
drinks with Jocelyn and hang out and pet
her dogs cuz they're the sweetest if you
don't know them follow her this is the
outfit that's happening much care very
style but let's go do that
log man yes okay BAE why not why not why
not it is Monday and I didn't edit my
blog my studio for today yeah yeah okay
I have to go home and edit this and then
post it immediately and then have
nothing to post for tomorrow which is so
exciting and she's got the coffee
meeting which is very exciting I didn't
get coffee I need coffee oh my god
there's a corgi corgis I like just very
obviously not bred for survival which i
think makes them charming I'm going to
jo-ann fabrics because I am making
Christmas gifts for memory and Hannah
you don't normally buy each other
Christmas gifts but then Hannah
sent me some flowers and broke the mold
and now I gotta get them Christmas gifts
this is all really great in theory I was
feeling they're gonna turn out predation
hey let's find out or the mayor I'm
gonna eat some people quite beautiful oh
look at you and your Christmas sweater
perfect nailing it clearly very low with
your own fashion is there something else
I want to show you no no you say that